>> Shannon: JOHN, THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
EARLIER IN THE DAY, THE
PRESIDENT SAYS HE'S FEELING
VIBRANT AND YOUNG AT AGE 72 AND
THINKS HE HAS A BIG ADVANTAGE IN
ENERGY OVER 76-YEAR-OLD
JOE BIDEN AND OUR DEMOCRATS
OTHER
DEMOCRATS LOOKING TO TAKE HIS JB
DEMOCRATS LOOKING TO TAKE HIS J.
NORMALLY WHAT WOULD BE
CONSIDERED FRIENDLY TERRITORY.
HERE'S CORRESPONDENT PETER DOOC
PETER DOOCY.
>> THIS IS JOE BIDEN'S FIRST
CAMPAIGN.
IT'S THE FIRST TIME HE'S ASKED
HIMSELF ABOUT WHAT'S APPROPRIAT
APPROPRIATE.
>> I ACTUALLY THOUGHT IN MY HEAD
WHEN I WALKED OUT HERE, DO I --
WE ARE FRIENDS.
>> BIDEN IS MUCH MORE FAMILIAR
WITH FUND-RAISING.
HIS CAMPAIGN HAS $3.6 MILLION IN
THE BANK.
THE HIGHEST OF ANY TOTAL
DEMOCRAT RUNNING.
HIS RECORD AS LONG.
HE RECENTLY CALLED ANITA HILL
ABOUT THE REGRET OF THE 1991
HEARING HE SHARED WHERE SOME
LAWMAKERS DOUBTED HER CLAIMS
ABOUT MISCONDUCT AGAINST
CLAIMANT'S COMMENTS.
APOLOGY NOT ACCEPTED.
HILL TELLS "THE NEW YORK TIMES,"
I CANNOT ACCEPT "I'M SORRY WHAT
HAPPENED TO YOU."
I WILL
>> I DON'T THINK I TREATED HER
BADLY.
>> THIS IS WHAT BIDEN SAID IN
1991.
>> IT IS APPROPRIATE TO ASK
PROFESSOR HILL ANYTHING ANY
MEMBER WISHES TO ASK HER, TO
PLUMB THE DEPTHS OF HER
CREDIBILITY.
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP'S FOCUS ISN'T
ON AN OLD HEARING, IT'S ON OLD
AGE.
>> I AM A YOUNG, VIBRANT MAN.
I LOOK AT THOUGH.
I DON'T KNOW ABOUT HIM.
>> TRUMP IS 72.
BIDEN IS 76.
>> IF YOU LOOK YOUNG AND VIBRANT
COMPARED TO ME, I PROBABLY
SHOULD GO HOME.
>> THE PRESIDENT IS ALSO TRYING
TO TAG HIM AS A MEDICAL
PRESIDENT JOE."
>> I SHOULD TELL YOU THIS, I
FEEL LIKE CARRIE TRUMAN.
I WENT TO THE BACK ROOM AND FELL
ASLEEP UNTIL IT WAS OVER.
>> BELIEVES THEY KEPT THINGS WE
COULD AT 1600.
>> NOT ONE SINGLE WHISPER OF
SCANDAL.
>> BUT PRESIDENT TRUMP ALLEGES
THAT SOMEONE IN THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR MAY BE THE BIGGEST SCANDAL
IN POLITICAL HISTORY, EVEN
BIGGER THAN WATERGATE.
THAT'S ORDERING SURVEILLANCE ON
HIS CAMPAIGN.
BIDEN MAY NOT HAVE HEARD A